I'm releasing the power I've received from everyone and stored up all at once
.
Was that the true identity of the ghost
? Ah,
I haven't been able to control my constitution yet, and if I get too close, I'll lose a lot of my magical power.
I got to my room and
found out that I was like this
And said that I didn't have magical powers so I didn't have to worry about being taken
away I mourned the child who came to play in
my heart  What the hell
8 more I'm going to go because I'm really sucking magic power
Shikada and you're at our diner
Yeah
[music]
Even if you want to protect your friends when Faith is able to move, put it on
[music] To the
amulet
[music]
Here,
when I think about it now